muy buenas noches Santiago todavía no la
verdad es que el presidente francés aquí
ha sido muy querido ha llegado ha estado
paseando por las calles de New Orleans
que estáis yendo detrás de mí se ha dado
un baño de masas porque aquí como decías
hay muchos expatriados franceses que
querían salir a saludar al presidente
Manuel macron lo hemos visto también
bailar delante de las cámaras hemos oído
ese grito de viva Francia y ha estado
paseando con la alcaldesa de esta ciudad
y con el vicegobernador y han llegado
hasta aquí a este edificio que estáis
viendo detrás de mí que es la colección
histórica de New Orleans aquí ha tenido
un encuentro con el gobernador de
Luisiana y junto y él y la ministra
francesa para Europa y asuntos
exteriores Katherine colon han firmado
un memorando en presencia del presidente
francés por el cual van a crear un
puesto dentro del grupo de trabajo para
la lucha contra el cambio climático
crearán un puesto para un experto
francés en transición
la verdad es que tiene todo sentido del
mundo que Luisiana sea este telón de
fondo para hablar sobre cambio climático
y sobre eso y sobre este tipo de
energías renovables porque es uno de los
estados más castigados por el cambio
climático aquí el nivel del agua va
subiendo cada vez más y amenaza la costa
además también en esas conversaciones
que han tenido se ha hablado también del
gas natural licuado no olvidemos que en
un momento en el que
debido
a la invasión por parte de Rusia en
Ucrania muchas naciones europeas están
buscando diferentes Fuentes y esta
podría ser una de ellas una amplia
agenda mamen que todavía resta algunos
puntos por finalizar de lo que resta de
este día apretado allí en Luisiana que
más le falta por hacer al presidente
allí
tremendamente apretado Santiago ahora
mismo está a punto de ofrecer un
discurso en el Museo de Arte de New
Orleans se espera que empiecen pocos
minutos y para reafirmar la cultura
francesa y su compromiso el compromiso
de Francia con promocionar aquí la
cultura francesa además también está
previsto que apruebe un fondo para
invertir en la enseñanza en escuelas
estadounidenses para que se enseñe el
francés en las escuelas estadounidenses
para que os hagáis una idea aquí en este
estado hay más de 32 programas de
inmersión del lenguaje francés y más de
150 maestros procedentes de Francia como
decías va a ser una agenda de lo más
apretada luego se espera que el
presidente francés pasee por el centro
de esta ciudad y disfrute de la mayor
atracción turística que hay aquí en New
Orleans que es no sé si lo podéis
Escuchar Precisamente en la música en
directo y sobre todo el jazz